how are you doing today sir
very good yeah it's uh a weekend here
we're shooting uh
umbrella academy season three at the
moment so um
the weekends are uh are pretty bunkers
because i've got my family here so i've
got the two kids and everything and
uh um normally like that i suppose that
work becomes
a holiday from the kids at times you
know because they're like so full-on
but um no it's uh it's good
everything is uh is going well on the
show and uh it's great to have my family
here normally i wouldn't have them with
me what i'm shooting because of the
covered rules and everything
uh they moved across with me which is
which is brilliant
oh believe me i have some questions
about umbrella but if you could guest
star on any tv series
what would you guest star on and why god
that's a good question because so many
now isn't that
it might if i was gonna say like my
favorite show of all time
um i am a huge friends fanatic
uh massive friends fanatic i i
didn't even realize that i knew quite so
much trivia about friends
but it was only when i met with other
people that were friends fanatics that i
realized i knew quite a lot and didn't
even know
um and it would so probably be that
um also because i had a huge crush
on jenna franklin growing up so it would
probably be to go meet her
[Music]
did you did you get into friends on your
own or is it also something you share
with your wife
um she's a big fan of the show as well
although it was something that i got
into
growing up you know it was kind of part
of my
uh my friday night i suppose when i was
a teenager
and we used to watch it as a family and
um
i just loved it you know i love the the
humor i love the
it felt like you were part of that
friendship group i suppose it was the
way and it was also a really great
education for
for youngsters growing up in a world
where you know you're surrounded by a
lot of like toxic stuff i suppose it was
a very friendly
way to kind of learn about relationships
and stuff and what
kind of goes on in those sort of things
so i just really enjoyed it for
the simplicity of it i suppose uh what
movie or movies do you think you've seen
the most oh
uh without a doubt i would say back to
the future
trilogy um and
terminator 2 judgment day i would say
they are what up there but then nowadays
i've probably seen
every pixar movie
countless times uh so
i would say that the yeah that they're
they're probably competing with about
the future movies now although
my daughter sat and watched the whole of
back to the future with me
for the first time ever which is a very
proud moment actually
because uh it's hard to get them to
watch anything other than pixar
i can't imagine what she's thinking
about time travel
no i know yeah yeah she should watch
umbrella academy as well that sort of
it's got education on that um when did
you think
that you made it as an actor that like
you could do this full-time and
pay your rent
uh i still don't i still i still panic
that i'm that i'm uh done after every
job you know like i think
um it's quite humbling being an actor i
think if you if you allow it to be
because
i i worked tirelessly for years
before i got work that i would consider
that there was
you know that allowed me to just live my
life purely as an actor
um you know i went a good three four
years for a drama school
and many times nearly was like i'm not
sure if i can do this you know because
it's so hard it was so
tough getting so many auditions that
then
just turned to nothing for a long time
um
but i suppose the first time that
it allowed me to have some kind of
security was when i got the job on
merlin
um back in i guess like 2010 something
like that
um and then it started to
things started to click you know things
started to
i suppose like you you build a
reputation or something i don't know
what it is but there's also a confidence
the more you work i suppose there's
more of a confidence going into the the
audition room and like when you read for
roles and stuff and you start to really
understand
what you're putting out there as a as a
product you know for people to
produce as directors whatever you know
to buy into
and um i think
that was the first turning point for me
when i when i joined the cast of merlin
and then on to black sails and then so
on and so forth from there
um but i i never sort of count my
chickens you know i'm always
i i'm always driving to do better i'm
always driving to become a better actor
to learn on every set i'm on and to
ultimately i think becoming a father is
a huge one because it
you strive to be successful for your
children to be inspiration for your
children and to
always be able to provide so you stop
thinking about
doing it for selfish reasons and i think
that's a really important thing that i
learned you know
once i started doing it for them and my
family and as a provider you
you let go of a few hang-ups you know
that you had before that we had
previously and i think it grounds you as
an actor
when you think back on merlin what's
like something that like the first thing
when you think about merlin
what comes to your mind um the uh the
brotherhood i think
uh of the nights you know the
when i first joined that it was like you
know sometimes you join cass and it
takes you a long time to get to know
the other cast members and stuff and
there was something weird about merlin
we all just kind of shared a car on the
first morning that we
all happened to be there um and
we kind of got on like an old group of
friends straight away
and there was lots of piss taken and
stuff straight away and like we
we it felt like something special early
on
and i became you know those guys are
still some of my best mates
and uh i don't think that will ever
change actually
you know even when we don't see each
other for years the banter never changes
and the
the fun factor and i i would kind of
love to
be on a job with those boys all over
again because
it's quite special you don't always get
that i believe
completely um same thing for black sales
when you think back on black sales
what's the first thing that comes to
your mind
um i suppose two things
the training aspect of it you know we've
got put through a
very intense boot camp and it was i
suppose life-affirming and also
life-changing but like
i realized how hard i could push my body
during that
that training process and how i suppose
like my
diet and stuff as well they put a very
strict diet to get all lean and
everything and
um it makes the initial part of black
sales was quite punishing i would say
until we started shooting and then the
other part i'd say was the sets you know
i'm still
yet to go on on a production where the
the sets are as impressive as black
sails you know we had these huge
spanish galleons and like an entire
pirate town
they made with a beach of water and
just a monumental set and it was just
a very intense but very enjoyable time
down in cape town south africa so
um you know i'm very thankful for that
period of time in my life
it was a was a gift of a show to be on
it really was
can you eat chicken every day or are you
by now just completely sick of it
uh i i could eat chicken i don't eat
chicken every day if i can
like mix it up i'm a big
i'm a big advocate of regenerative
farming and
trying to eat the right kind of meat and
the right kind of
because i do eat um i do eat meat you
know on a regular basis so i think it's
important you make the right choice with
with meat but chicken yeah i mean we ate
a lot of it during black sales that's
for sure chicken and broccoli
every every two to three hours which was
pretty draining after all but
one thing i've realized with my own
research and
just my life in making healthy choices
now is that
healthy food doesn't have to be boring
and
i i get a real kick out of making really
healthy food taste amazing
so um that's kind of my goal now is like
to make sure that i never get bored of
things like chicken away because i can
make it in a different way every time to
make it delicious
i need to take some notes um so
uh you joined game of thrones in
basically the height of popularity um
i'm i'm just curious
when you got the role did they tell you
you're only gonna be on this season how
much did they tell you about the arc of
your character
um when you got involved yeah so
they let me know exactly what was the
the deal with the character
um and the thing is with so they said
you know you come in
you're part of the battle and everything
and then um and then you die in
this episode and my immediate question
was
how do i die because the thing is
with game of thrones i always found was
really important was
what kind of death you had you know how
did you die depends on how whether
you're gonna be memorable or not as a
character as you know and
what you do before the death so they
said it was uh
firings effectively a firing squad by
dragon
and i said i like that
so uh yeah that kind of sold it to me
and the thing is with game of thrones
you know you don't
like you say it was at the height of its
popularity it it did
amazing things for my career after being
on that show and you don't turn down
game of thrones you know it's
it was one that you uh it can really
be an audition on the world stage you
know to show
to show you're acting so i didn't want
to let that opportunity go so it was
it was great i enjoyed it and i thought
the death turned out really well i was
really pleased with how it turned out
and
um i thought they gave that moment
with dickon and his father you know like
a nice amount of weight
actually in the in the episode and it
was it turned out to be a really lovely
scene
that's something that i think a lot of
people don't realize maybe outside the
industry is that
when you are on something incredibly
popular um
you're being put in front of every
casting director
there is without having to get in the
room with them
yeah totally you know and steve blackman
the showrunner of umbrella academy
you know he saw me on game of thrones
and then um
straight after that asked me to audition
for luther on umbrella
so um you know because he saw me on that
i got that opportunity and that he kind
of put put me in the front of his mind
for the role so yeah
it was i'm hugely thankful for game of
thrones the opportunity it gave me
um and same with amy schumer actually i
did this movie called i feel pretty
and amy schumer watched me as dick on
and was watching and they had they
hadn't found a character in this movie
um and then found an actor for this
character and uh
she said i was watching i was just
watching game of thrones
and she was like it was just the
character was called grant and she was
like
he should be grant
and then my agent got a call and they
said you want to play this character and
i feel pretty with amy schumer and i was
like oh yeah sounds great
so it was this bizarre like my wife
always laughs about it you know that
you know the the two three weeks the
game of thrones came out
um you know there was a period before
game of thrones came out though i was
like auditioning a lot and was trying to
find the next gig and couldn't quite
make the next gig happen and then game
of thrones came out and then
everything changed you know it's a very
very powerful show
you know the the the that you know the
powers that has is
unbelievable really uh last thing on
that series
what surprised you coming into that that
uh maybe you weren't expecting or what
was it like behind the scenes on the
making of a show like that
i suppose what surprised me the most and
i suppose it shouldn't have done in the
end because it's such a well-oiled
machine
um looking back but for the scale
of the show you know how big it was how
many moving parts there are
um how many different units are shooting
at any given time you know like in
you know the one in iceland there's one
in spain there's one in the uk there's
one in ireland you know whatever
they're all over the place it surprised
me how well organized it was
there was no you know so many sets you
go on it can be very
um chaotic at times you know especially
when there's a lot of moving parts
and they just felt so calm i couldn't
believe how calm it felt and organized
and i think what they've done is they by
the time i got it they've gotten
a a crew you know a lot of leaders
amongst the crew who just knew what they
were doing very
well they just slide into place so like
i say it was a very well oiled machine
and that
i was like pleasantly surprised about
how well it was put together
jumping into uh the reason i actually
get to talk to you today for sas red
notice um
one of the things that i really enjoy
about the movie is that you can watch it
as like a fun popcorn movie
but there's also a real subtext to the
script
dealing with what like is going on with
most likely governments around the world
can you sort of talk about that aspect
yeah it's what really surprised me
actually after reading the script
and then talking to uh andy mcnabb in
depth about these sort of things that
how much of this sort of thing is going
on you know behind the scenes
and uh you know the sort of thing that
declare my character goes through
is happening fairly regularly you know
like having the opportunity to go and
work in the private sector and
earn a lot of money for themselves and
that sort of things happen
and it makes you i suppose
it's quite apt you know with with what's
going on in 2020 you know with
everything you're i'm
i'm constantly questioning what's going
on behind the scenes you know i always
i'm always going
hang on a minute that can't be right
there has to be something deeper than
that
going on and movies like this when you
have an insider you know like andy who's
worked
on the other side of it and dealt with a
lot of these politics
you realize that it isn't just as black
and white as the press
put out there you know and it's there's
far more going on which is
uh enlightening but worrying
well completely but i i think the
problem is that and maybe
obviously it's just my opinion but you
know a lot of people are just content
to um keep their head down and not
really worry about what's going on over
there if it gets me my
oil for a dollar a gallon and my coffee
for
you know 50 cents or whatever the prices
are obviously these are much lower
prices than
for real yeah yeah that's it you know
and i think
one thing i've learned in my life so far
is to
uh always ask why you know always
question
question question question because
sometimes when one person says something
a lot of people just take it as gospel
of you know that's
that's what it is you know like so oh i
better not ask any more questions
someone of authority you know like a
doctor says you need to have your
you know leg chopped off so i get a
second opinion ask why
you know whatever it is um and it's the
same with
all these sort of things you know i
don't see why we should just sort of
sort of roll over and go okay well
that's what it is then so well
maybe you should ask why more you know
and if more people did that then maybe
we wouldn't just
uh have to put up with you know certain
things that go on and we don't even know
about
uh something else that i enjoyed about
the movie is that ruby's character
in 99 out of 100 movies is played by a
man
and i like that it had you know let's
just call it what it is like
and i like that it's a female-led um
character can you sort of talk about
that aspect of the film
yeah well i think what it proves is that
women can be
uh functioning psychopaths as much as a
man can
and uh they uh if not more actually in
in this case and uh yeah i think
what it depicts is you know the high
how uh you know you you mix that with
high skill level it gender is completely
you know irrelevant doesn't make a
difference um
and uh i you know i've seen women
fight in you know in the ufc and
mixed martial arts and stuff and who
would kick my ass
so that you know in terms of how like
how
physically strong she is and how skilled
she is you know that
that gap i suppose between men and women
of
and showing physicality and who would
win a fight
you know when it comes down to skill and
training you know that that gap is made
very much smaller so i really liked that
actually i really liked that she was
a very highly skilled soldier basically
when you got involved in the project
how much are they telling you about you
know the full arc of the character how
much is your agent telling you
this this and this and how much are
people telling you just read the script
tell me what you think
uh well the first thing that happens
yeah is you get the script and if you
like the script then
um you know you take it to the next the
next step and then
i went and had a meeting with larry
malkin and magnus the
the director and uh producer um
and we basically just chatted for like a
good hour and a half two hours
about the script and about the character
and what i would want to bring to it you
know
the the biggest thing for me with these
kind of movies is that
they're not cut and dry good guys bad
guys you know everyone is
human and they're making mistakes and
they're making
you know they're having moral struggles
and ethics and stuff and that's what
decline was to me you know
like you can come across as opposed like
he betrays tom in the movie and
you've got to look at his motives behind
that and that's why i really liked that
he actually really struggled there was
no
it wasn't it wasn't clean cut for me you
know that he was just like the bad guy
you know i said it was really important
that
the the humane side of this character is
the thing that drives it
and the action and the the rest of the
story drive it you know
um so or compliment it i should say so
it was
it was a very long conversation with
larry you know that we we decided
what declan should be um and then in
turn you know talking to
andy mcnabb about that more and more how
much
are you at the point do you still get
nervous the night before you're gonna
sit down with a director and people like
that
and you're like please let me not say
the wrong [ __ ] thing or
are you sort of like what's gonna be is
gonna be
um i think i don't get nervous because
i'm always
prepared you know because i think you
know
nerves come from uh panic i suppose or
like
like you say like a worry that you're
gonna say the wrong thing and i for me
if i
know what i want to get out the project
and i understand what it's saying and i
this is my version of it you know i'm
prepared if
i've got to read for a role then i've
got to learn my lines
all i can do is give my version of that
role and
discuss what i feel it is and if that's
not in line with what they think then i
can't do anything about that that's just
you know
the way i see it um obviously there's
always
like wiggle room in that but it's uh
ultimately like
i feel like nerves don't serve you so um
i certainly get excited when it's about
a project that i really want to do or
like read those so i was excited to go
into the meeting
but it's uh it's a different kind of
butterflies you know it's like a
controlled butterflies in your stomach
rather than
uh certainly no panic yeah trying to
avoid that like what's the day or two
that you'll always remember
i suppose one was when we stormed the
house when me and
sam stormed the house at the beginning
of the movie that was a lot of fun to do
and we
we did a lot of kind of one shots that
ran all the way through the house and
would just follow up with the camera so
he
you very much felt immersed in that
world and the the gas canisters were
going off and flashbangs and stuff
and because we've done our training you
know we felt very organized so me and me
and sam started to really get a flow
together
so that will stick in my head i suppose
um and then i think the first day when i
saw the tunnel
when i saw the set of the tunnel and the
train um
was very impressive you know i remember
starting
you what's great about the movie is that
you as an actor you immediately felt
immersed because the set they built
was legit so you
you never had to imagine anything you
were in a you were like in the channel
tunnel it was great
i thought you filmed on location i'm
kidding but
um so uh i really enjoyed hitman's
bodyguard
made me laugh a lot you're in the sequel
uh
what can you say about it what was it
like making that film
it was a lot of fun um i'm not sure what
i can
really say about it because i think uh
there's a few spoilers in there if i
talk too much but i have to say there
was it was
it was the first time that i i really
had to sort of take myself back and
look at where i was in in terms of a set
you know because i was
doing a scene with these major names
people that i've been watching
since i was a kid and admiring their
work
um you know it was
it was a very odd scenario for me so
being a part of that movie just being a
part of moving having the opportunity to
work with those
those actors was um was a huge privilege
you know just that alone
but also the fun i had on it you know it
was it's going to be a really fun movie
i'd say it's like in terms of the uh the
laughs and the action it's
right up there with the first one um if
not more and better
so um i'm excited to see what people
think it's a shame that kobe happened
what it did for that movie you know
because it's not to obviously be
delayed but i think it's gonna be worth
the wait uh frank grillo told me
that he had a blast making it and he
drank too much wine
uh what about you um
i had a blast making it i didn't drink
any wine uh
but uh um i
i get to uh i i get to do some nice uh
nice fight scenes i'll say that and uh
have some good fun doing that
which you know fighting fighting in a
suit always makes me feel a bit more
like james bond which is always nice
uh the thing about it is obviously you
have scenes or must have a scene with
ryan
and sam um ryan improvises and
is so good and sam i'm sure when he's
cursing or if he's cursing at you
you're gonna break and laugh how many
takes did you ruin
in any of those scenes with them i was
so terrified of ruining a take that i
i've had my best non-corpse face on
um yeah there's a few times though that
like there's a few times that
ryan nearly got me right because ryan
throws some curveballs you know
um but and he's so good at it
but i think yeah i was so uh
i was so aware of not ruining any takes
that i uh
i have my best face on but they they
their chemistry between those guys is
fantastic like it's just
to watch it in person is is quite
something so
um no i think audiences are in for a
treat on that one
i am looking forward to resident evil
which is a
film coming out in september right now
tentatively
um what do you want people to know about
the new resident evil movie
um i think fans of the game will be
happy
um but at the same time i think they
should you know recognize that we want
to make
uh these characters as real and as
grounded as possible so you know i think
that
one thing i said about wesker is i
didn't want him to be
i feel like the wesker in the game
obviously has that kind of like mr smith
from the matrix type
idea and i wanted to be a bit more you
know three-dimensional than that you
know and
um have again like you know
a a moral high ground and he it's not
just as cut and dry as
as uh is in the game but i think it's
also
there's an origin element to wesker you
know in this
and what he maybe was uh before he
turned into the the one we see in a lot
of the games but
i think from an aesthetic point of view
i think the games
um really influenced this well and it
kind of there's an aesthetic
that certainly when we were shooting it
that i was like man it feels
feels like a game so i think i'm really
hoping that fans of the game might take
something nice away from it that it's
the game
plus more you know plus more uh more of
a depth to these characters
would you describe the movie as violent
or super violent
oh it probably slips into super violent
at times at times
yeah right i'm really uh
i'm looking forward to it but i i think
that the movie um
uh deals with the first two games so i'm
just curious
when are when you're getting ready to do
this role are you sort of justifying to
your wife i listen i gotta play video
games tonight
it's really it's for work like you gotta
let me do it
that was the thing yeah i said tour i
was like this is because johannes the
director was like
the one thing i want you to do is uh
get into the game you know like start
playing the game i was like this is the
best research i've ever done for a game
for a movie this is like the best i just
get to go and play a game
so um yeah i got the old they got the
playstation out and got the game and
started playing it and
say what i pooed my pants
at least once
it's incredibly scary but i think as
well that's the thing with the game is
like more than a movie you're in control
of this you decide oh should i go around
that corner what's behind that corner
what's behind that what's behind that
and you have to kind of make the
decision yourself and
uh that's that's what's so kind of
immersive i suppose about the games and
i think we've tried to do that in the
movie you know i think we've tried to
give the audience that kind of feel that
it feels like a
horror that you're in that you're
involved in well i think for people that
maybe don't realize this is a full
reboot of resident evil this does not
connect to the other movies
and as far as i'm aware it takes place
in 1998.
can you sort of talk about um how this
doesn't connect to the other movies
yeah well like you say you know there's
no real connection
at all to uh the previous films so
we are literally going back to you know
more of the game
and with that said like you say 1998 you
know
that's when it's effectively set so
there's a lot of like nostalgia and
we're using using a lot of the gear
that was around then and i was like as i
was making them we were looking you know
the costumes i was like oh my god it's
so brilliantly 90s
that was the years that i grew up so i'm
remembering a lot of these things that
were around them
and a lot of sets had nostalgic things
from the 90s and everything so
um i think that's another factor of how
it does take you into the game because
the original game
you know it definitely feels like that i
read a quote uh
from uh i want to johannes uh
and uh he said we wanted to we even
wanted to use the fixed angles
that the first game has when the
characters are at spencer
mansion that's right yeah yeah
so there is a lot of that sort of stuff
yeah where
i mean the spencer mansion yeah it feels
like the game at times you know it's
quite when we stepped into it it was a
bit like going into one of those vr
things you know when you go into the vr
world
that's what it was like you know it was
it was like playing the game
especially like they're all geared up
with our guns and stuff it was pretty
pretty cool uh last thing on this on
this one when you think back on the
shoot i've asked you this on other
things what's like the day or two that
you'll always remember
and of course did you borrow anything
from sets because i know you wouldn't
have stolen anything
i did borrow some things um
i've got my i kept my uh my wesker
police badge and my police shirt
my raccoon silly uh my raccoon city
police department
t-shirt and badge so that's cool to keep
and then uh the first of my my favorite
i suppose my most memorable
i guess getting to shoot a zombie was
pretty pretty memorable and then uh
i would say the moment we were first
walked into the spencer mansion
was a real kind of like we all kind of
love to use it again holy [ __ ] it's so
cool
um so i think those things those things
really stick in my mind yeah
actually one last thing what was it um
what was your reaction reading the
script for the first time
was it were you a little surprised at
what it was tackling
like what can you tell fans about it um
not that much unfortunately but i can
say that i was
i think because of the whole game
aspects i always think you know
there was there's been previous films
and i was thinking
how's this one going to be different you
know and the one thing that i've
been told by my team and everything is
like this is like going back it's like a
whole new starter and it should it's one
that's gonna try and hopefully please
the
the fans of the game so when i started
reading it it really felt like
like more like a script from a game you
know from one of the games it felt like
um immersive and it felt like
dirtier you know it felt um
it felt like raccoon city was a a grim
place to kind of be and i
i immediately felt like it was a world
that i i
kind of related to more than anything
like i've seen towns like this in
america
that's what excited me about it that it
felt relatable i think
even though you've got influence in the
game it felt like a relatable um
place to live last thing i wanted to
talk to you about uh of course is
umbrella
i am a huge fan of the series and so
thankful that netflix is making a third
season and hopefully many more
um what was it like for you stepping
back on the set for the first time
for season three well
um covid protocol has changed a lot
number one so we could actually shoot
the thing so we've got to have a lot of
rules and regulations in place that we
can actually shoot it
um but i know the scripts are so great
for season three like i'm
you know it's it's really such a joy
to be doing it um
i feel you know very privileged to be a
part of this this show and
uh i think the best thing really is that
you know we're all we're all so
comfortable with each other now
so it feels like we can really hit the
ground running from a creative
standpoint
and we've got the same crew you know
most of the same crew and
um i think we know who these characters
are and who we are playing them and
who you know i think when we work with
each other we're very aware of
of how to react and you know in these
scenes so
as a family you know i think we're we're
in a great place and it's
it's like when a good sports team i
suppose when a sports team really finds
that flow
you know and they you know they go on a
winning streak it feels a bit like that
you know
we're very we're very fortunate to have
a very talented
uh cast and and crew did kovid
impact the shooting schedule of season
three were you originally
gonna film it earlier or how did that
affect anything
i'm not sure i think we were actually
supposed to originally shoot a little
bit earlier
um i'm not sure only the only thing the
good thing that
came out of it was it allowed me to
shoot resident evil
because resident evil was probably
originally going to be a clash but then
that
that allowed me to shoot that but um
it was good because it allowed my family
and stuff to come out with me in january
and
and start with them so no yeah it was
i think this is this is a good schedule
we started on uh i've spoken to a lot of
uh writers
and showrunners and they've all told me
that the pandemic while
terrible for the planet and obviously
the worst thing ever
um has actually been good in terms of
the writing process for a lot of movies
and tv shows
because it allowed a lot of people to
get ahead on scripts
and spend more time on the scripts that
they normally wouldn't be able to
and you mentioned already that you were
really happy with the writing
um did you get um all 10 scripts already
did you just get some of them
how did that work yeah we've had a fair
chunk yeah we've
we've not got all 10 but we've had a
fair chunk and
yeah i think you're right you know i
think you did allow them to have a bit
of extra time on
um because i think we got commissioned
you know in the middle of all this stuff
so
the writers i guess got yeah more of a
head start so
um and that's only allowed them to kind
of like really refine them so the ones
we're getting now are really
special uh i interviewed gerard way
before the first season came out
and he told me that he gave steve an
18-page document
that basically told him everything
including the eight
the other graphic novels that had not
been written yet he like gave steve at
all
uh so how much have you asked steve
to be like hey so you're gonna tell me
everything or how much are you finding
out season by season no
i'm the opposite man i live i i have to
do everything in the moment i'm kind of
like
episode by episode because i don't want
to know like what's happening like way
in advance
so i know that some people like need to
know kind of
they want to know everything that's
going to happen whereas i'm kind of the
opposite i'm uh
i wouldn't even look at like episode
four and five until i'm like
done on one two and three so
uh i like to really kind of take my time
with it
uh i believe where are you actually in
the filming process i think i heard that
you
you guys are shooting till september
which is a long shoot
yeah well the kobe protocols mean that
we have like shorter days
um which means that the actual length of
the shoot is going to be a lot longer
um but yeah we're
kind of really near the beginning you
know we're not that far into it at the
moment
um so we've got a long way to go but
it's good the thing is the
the great thing is the material the work
is amazing so every day on stage
like i say a joy and so much fun looking
backwards i loved season two
i loved the time jump i loved it was
especially the opening episode the
action
and the finale like it's just a great
season but now that you can talk about
it
um because you obviously you can talk
about it before what what did you take
away from season two and what were your
thoughts on the finale
um i loved it i think it's a great setup
for season three
um i i thought that the the show really
sort of
found a groove you know i think it like
what was so great about season two is
that we we'd set up the world in season
one you know and i really feel that
season one was almost like a set
up for the rest of the show isn't we
you're not trying to figure out what
this world is anymore you know who these
characters are you know where they're
they're at in their lives and and then
we can really get things going and
i think towards the end of season two
you really start to just
see what this show is you know and
uh it's it's a great setup for what
what's gonna happen in
in three um i'm just curious if you
could talk a little bit about uh
uh things that maybe fans fans of the
series might not realize
about the making of the series is there
anything that you wish like they knew
anything that might surprise people
about the behind the scenes
and it might surprise people um i mean
it depends what you know about
making a tv show you know um
[Music]
i think one thing you have to
realize as well is that the the true
genius behind the show
is the writers in steve blackman and
netflix you know
these guys give us i think what
and it probably comes across you know
but they they have this amazing writing
on the page
already like from the from the back
you're reading these scripts you know
this is just gold
and a joy as an actor to do and then
on top of that like steve says you know
always give me like one that's on the on
the script
but then feel free to play you know play
around like be creative
see where the scene evolves to um and
that for actors
um you know people might not know that
you know on other shows you don't have
that
that lenience and that kind of creative
uh
flow and allowance and uh they give us
that on this show which is
which is amazing you know like they um
they don't they don't kind of hold us
back you know we're quite we're quite
free to
try stuff as long as we give them stuff
on the page which is you know like i say
like so nice to do how does it work with
uh preparing for the action on a show
like this
do you typically have a lot of time for
rehearsals are you learning
moves on the day like how does that work
um it varies really most of the time we
get a pretty decent amount of prep time
uh
especially if it's a big fight you know
like the last season like david who
plays diego he had like a big one
shot you know so he had to you have to
prepare these things and i those big
fights in the
in the uh the underground fighting ring
and stuff so
they're they're pretty well rehearsed
and then sometimes you know you have
moments where
we're like kind of on the fly and we
like there's a moment that needs to be
out then you gotta like just jump in and
do it and sometimes
they're the best because it's not
rehearsed or over rehearsed you know you
can just
uh kind of have these little action
moments or like a fall or a stunt or
something
um and i quite enjoy those kind of
moments actually
you never know when you sign on to a
series if it's going to be popular if
people are going to respond to it
um what what was your reaction with
umbrella academy because
right out of the gate it was a big show
and season two was even bigger
so what's been your reaction to the
reception to the series
i think um gratitude number one that
people actually
really enjoyed you know tuning into it
um
because there's always like a there's a
the pressure especially with like
uh source material you know already had
an existing fan base
so there's a responsibility we had to
obviously serve that audience
before everything else on top of it and
actually making the show something that
lots of people will enjoy not just fans
of the comic
um but it kind of blew me away man it
blew me away like i couldn't believe
that
i think sometimes you know a show can
feel good when you're shooting it or
like some of the movie it can feel good
everything feels like it's good
you never really know you never know how
it's going to hit and then
i think why it hit so well was it kind
of hits multiple demographics you know
it's enjoyable for
parents to watch with their kids and i
think a lot of families watched it
together and like couples watch it
together
so it seemed to seem to hit a lot of
notes
and different demographics so more than
anything just
surprised how well it did you know i
think i expected it to do okay i think i
always expected people to watch it but
i was like blown away about how well i
did yeah
actually this is my last thing for fans
of the series uh
what can you tease about season three or
what do you want them to know
if anything i just wanted to know
that if they've loved the first two
seasons
um we've upped the ante like big time
and if um the fun factor is up
um i think the wow factors up um and i
think they're just gonna fall in love
with these characters even more
i really hope so anyway and i think we
just we've just added so many
like more little injections of of juice
into there and
uh yeah i hope it's i hope it's
everything they hope it is
um i'm gonna stop there because you've
given me a ton of time and i'm just
gonna say thank you
thanks so much man i really appreciate
it